hope i've got enough breaths left to
finish this review
[Music]
oxygen
it has been too long since i've seen
this particular episode of doctor who
and it is
i love this one i love its construction
i love its thematic elements i love how
the more i think about it the more i'm
like yeah that's a really good way to
make the point you're trying to make
about the whole thing the performances
are great
it's like the this is just awesome
that said it opens a little weak but i'm
gonna forgive it because it's kind of a
misdirect
because the opening which sets up the
station and you know the that people are
dying yet still moving around
it's not a particularly solid opening
and it makes it look i remember first
time i watched it thinking oh
great space zombies
you know aside from kind of being over
zombies in a lot of ways especially if
you're just going to do zombies straight
which was what it looks like from that
opening
and combine that with the fact that you
know i felt like doctor who had
taken its shot at zombies with the flood
in waters of mars i wasn't too excited
well
it's not what it looks like and so i
actually
only in hindsight does the cold open
become clever because you realize
oh it made me think this is one thing
and it
so is not it's a really good way at
not broadcasting your intentions right
at the front end of the thing so i do
applaud at that
and from there we then get the doctor
lecturing in this case
just about space and the way that being
in space
will kill you his his exact word space
wants to kill us it's great i i
really kind of wish that they had
used this as part of the front end of
more episodes
for series 10 because i really do like
him as a professor
in a lecture hall just cutting loose
with whatever the heck he felt like
talking about
i think it was unnecessary for them to
button it with a joke of the fact that
he was supposed to be lecturing on
something else what's this got to do
with crop rotation we've already kind of
established that he did this we
established that back
in the first episode in the pilot so it
i didn't need that reiterated but you
know that
didn't kill the scene either because
again i like it
the whole thing with nardole and the
doctor and bill
going i love that too i love it for
multiple reasons first of all there's
just some great dialogue i thought i
sent you to birmingham for a packet of
crisps yeah i saw through your cunning
ruse
great banter i love the banter and then
the
fluid link now this is not only funny
in the scene in and of itself but it's a
brilliant callback this is the best kind
of callback
in my mind because the way the whole
scene plays out with nardole
saying see this fluid link i don't know
what it does but the tardis can't go
anywhere
without it we told you that you did
exactly
what teach you to trust me i love it
because first of all
this works 100 in and of itself the
scene in isolation
works you don't need to know that this
is a callback but if you do
it's great because the fluid link is
something that has come up before
way back in classic who and specifically
did
actually ground the tardis which it may
just be in there as like
a gag thing realistically at some point
because it's all the way back in the
daleks the very second story of doctor
who
the fluid link did actually ground them
they couldn't leave the plant they
couldn't leave scaro
because they didn't have it so
definitely at some point
it did mean that the tardis had to have
it
but for me that just builds an implied
bit of lord that the doctor keeps
tinkering with the tardis
which is that's that's my head ganon for
what he keeps doing with the sonic
screwdriver why it has a bajillion
settings that it can do
he just keeps messing with it and i
think and i like to think he does the
same with the tardis like
boy that whole thing with a fluid link
that was a pain in the butt maybe i
should make it so it still
functions even without it and now we get
payoff for that theoretical thing that
i'd now like to believe happened
now overall i would hesitate to call
this episode particularly scary but it
is
very ominous and it's got a great
atmosphere
and there's good tension building as it
goes along right from when they land
because you get that thing right off the
bat unauthorized oxygen you're like
wait what and i love that even though
they're getting a
million red flags like maybe we
shouldn't be here and we should leave
the doctor won't leave
because he knows just from the lifetime
readings that there's four survivors
and he won't leave if there's survivors
on board he hasn't met them
he hasn't found them he does not have
visual confirmation that they exist
but he believes they do and he's not
going to leave because of that yes
we get a great series of escalations
with the o2 getting expelled
i love that it's established that the
reason that they can get in the suits
that they do
is because they were offline for repair
so it establishes right off the bat
these things are going to malfunction
repeatedly so it feels far
less like a plot convenience when
something goes wrong because normally
that can kind of happen it's like oh
yeah you know it's like the horror movie
when somebody like gets in their car and
they're trying to start their car to run
away from the killer and like the car
won't start like yeah
of course the car won't stop crosses
there's a killer no no it's very firmly
established that these things are
faulty that's why they weren't online in
the first place so that's
built in right off the bat so that's
awesome the screw the sonic screwdriver
actually gets
busted properly busted not it's
ineffective not oh it's deadlocked
sealed i can't do anything no
crushed that does not happen very often
i'm kind of surprised it happens as
infrequently as it does
because that's a really good way to
without
requiring technobabble for why the sonic
screwdriver doesn't work just
oh okay we got problems so when they
actually find the survivors there's the
there's a little bit of the extended
thing between bill and
i unfortunately forget his name but the
the blue
um character great we rescued a racist
well excuse me and like his delivery is
funny i don't
love the joke it's not that it's
bad that i don't know for how
nicely and smartly uh integrated a lot
of the other themes are with this that
felt
very on the nose and very clunky on the
one hand like it's kind of interesting
to
think about in terms of like once
the the human race starts encountering
other people
that their own differences in skin tone
within
the species doesn't matter anymore and
racism now means like
literally a different race of people um
because
the blue guy says like what do you mean
what what do you mean someone who's been
prejudiced to you he just doesn't
understand why that would be the case so
like that
that's not that it's a bad observation
it's just that doesn't
slot into everything else that's going
on and it feels
not badly out of place but i can't
decide if it's only being done for a
joke or if they think they're making a
bigger point but they don't have time to
make that point because they got other
points to make so let's get into some of
the themes on this one
now first off i'm on the record
as being pretty critical of uh
capitalism
yeah i've got issues but
i really love this
whole thing and the realization that
nothing's wrong
nothing's broken this is the system
working as intended because
and you know what if you can't handle
some of my political views
in a review bow out now but um
that is a lot of capitalism at its core
a lot of the stuff you're like wait what
is in fact the system working as
intended
you know the fact that there isn't
enough
food or health care or you know
if people can't get work that they
starve and go hungry
that's not a fault that's what the
system's designed
to do if you don't meet what is
believed by the capitalistic system to
be some form of use or utility or
contribute
you will be left to your own devices i.e
no assistance to probably die
now we don't like to paint it like that
nobody does because
whether you object to it or not you
still live in a capitalistic society and
i certainly have benefited from it
across my life and continued to
and yet i criticized it does that make
me a hypocrite ah maybe but you know
what if it screwed up it screwed up
but that's kind of my point this big
realization that
them being killed because their
productivity was so low
and a whole new crew being brought in
this is not
some sinister plan it's not a heist it's
not a malfunction it's not the ai going
wacky
this is what the system's supposed to do
they were unproductive get rid of them
bring in new people
dispose of the organic components
now i've seen some criticisms of this
episode basically
that amounted to something to the extent
of yeah but like it's too extreme
you know actual businesses wouldn't do
that
well i i've got a couple of problems
with this objection
the first is that first of all it's in
the far future you don't know what
the current normal for what companies
can get away with
is so like that's presumptuous of you to
say but even
you know what set that aside it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
if this is realistic this is what good
speculative fiction does it takes
something whether it be a piece of
technology whether it be an
aspect of society whatever and
extrapolates it
to the far end what is the ultimate end
point of something like this
does it mean that it's literally the
same thing and they're saying this is
what's happening right now
no but they are saying like look on a
tree on an unchanged trajectory
that's where you're going and like you
can criticize or you can try and
criticize and be like
oh like that's that's so on the nose and
it's like it's
we would never let it get there and you
know what and hopefully in reality we
wouldn't but it's fiction they're
allowed to take it to that extreme now
i will say that this whole slippery
slope thing which this is basically
the narrative equivalent of a slippery
slope argument because if you start from
the position of
companies won't provide food to their
employees they
they if they have a cafeteria at a
company you have to come in you have to
pay for it yourself even though food
would allow them to be able to work
and continue to work effectively they
still make them pay for it you
extrapolate that out to the point that
yes we make them pay for the air they
breathe that is a logical extrapolation
it's a slippery slope argument now if
you ever try and use a slippery slope
argument
in real life i will absolutely shut you
down you're allowed to do it in
fiction heck most of the best dystopian
apocalyptic or far-flung future fiction
with a sci-fi bent to it
does this somewhere to some degree with
something
i think it's wonderful i think it's
really really well thought out and well
integrated and i love this idea of this
sort of
mythical almost union that like they
don't even know if it exists
unionized i'm sorry i don't know who
said that
and honestly although it never gets
labeled as as this
in many ways the doctor's solution which
is to tie the destruction of the
base to their life signs meaning when
they die the baseball is up that is in
many ways
the ultimate extrapolation of a union
action
if you dispose of us you lose everything
just like this extrapolation uh that
they've done with capitalism they
extrapolate to an extreme version of a
union action
it's all been scaled up properly and
there was a line
that i love and i had not remembered
this line but i love it everyone says
it's not their fault well yes
it is it's all your fault so what are
you going to do about it
i love that line as a mission statement
honestly i would take that line
as like a life philosophy because
so often in fiction and in reality
people look at the situation and how
screwed up it is
and they go with i didn't create this
so it's not my fault
well the thing is if you're part of the
system
whether you're the one who designed it
or not you are a contributor
it is your fault and the thing is you
can make all the excuses and the
rationalizations you want about why it's
more somebody else's fault than yours
or whatever but it's still your fault
you're part of this society you're a
contributor in some way this is your
fault and what i love about that is not
that
because it's that line at the end what
are you going to do about it because
ultimately it's not about blaming it's
not about the doctor being like
you screwed up it's about the doctor
saying
take responsibility and
act and that's why versus
say orphan 55 which was the doctor
just waving a finger and going you
screwed up
in your time humanity's busy arguing
over the washing up while the house
burns down
and even though that like came with a
warning like don't let this happen it
just
felt like blame with this with capaldi
with this line with that added bit at
the end
what are you going to do about it he's a
challenge he's
not order you but he's challenging you
to step up
take responsibility and do something
it's awesome there are little tiny
things
nitpicky about it like i don't love that
when they get back
to their own time the doctor kind of
implies that within six months the
entirety of
because of this because it goes public
that the entirety of the capitalistic
system collapses in on itself and is
replaced with something else
i i don't have a problem with the idea
of a capitalistic society being replaced
by something else honestly that sounds
kind of nice
but like the idea that it happens in six
months more or less
cleanly uh no like that that
felt for something as pointedly
cynical as the rest of this episode was
that seemed
weirdly pie in the sky like if everyone
just
just agreed that this was bad it would
all change i'm like
no you got embedded systems you gotta
dismantle dude this is a
it's gonna be a decades if not
centuries-long process to
fix but i mean maybe that's me
hoping for too much from uh from a
45-minute sci-fi
show but i don't know the implication
that now that it's gone this far
it'll be easily dismantled didn't sit
right with me there are a lot of other
beyond the theming there's a lot of
other very visceral stuff that i love
bill having to go out unprotected first
of all they set that up great
with a doctor's opening lecture so
they've already set up how
why we should be scared of this it's
done from bill's perspective so you get
that sense through the
visuals and the auditory things that
they do with it of what it's like it
honestly reminds me a lot of what they
did with deep breath
with clara when they had her hold his
breath for her hold her breath for as
long as possible and
like all the things they did with the
visuals and the audio for that
it felt like that again i really like
when doctor who gets intense in that way
i love that the doctor going blind
sticks i love that there are lasting
consequences to that
i'll get into that a little bit more
into the next one i
i don't think it was necessary to kill
bill twice i mean granted we weren't led
to believe that
she actually was dead the first time but
like they put her immortal danger
twice in pretty rapid succession and it
felt
excessive i don't think we needed the
second one
but it didn't it doesn't kill the um
the upside and it's even got some good
moments in it with
just just tell me
a joke you know trying to get him to to
be
light about it because he has been he's
still been you know being like telling
jokes acting
even with his blindness i can like no no
this is fine but
he won't in that moment right before she
dies
you know with that second go but again
i'm still not sure it needed the second
time around
but you know what overall nitpicks aside
i love this episode
oxygen's great and i love it even more
the second viewing like
realizing how well thought out the
theming of capitalism is
in this one especially given that it's
picking up on stuff that was done
earlier this
season this series because like thin ice
was dealing with some similar topics if
not coming out them from the same angle
so
similar themes new angle new product
love it
doctor who oxygen you rewatched it
lately what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff to do
like share subscribe i have a patreon
and that is how i pay the bills and keep
this entire thing up
and running it is how i afford to
breathe these breaths which i use
to speak to you but at the end of the
day you do not
have to help me out in these ways i
would greatly appreciate it i encourage
it but
i'm not your boss you're the council
maybe a union of sorts i'm just running
the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
bye